this video is all about survival time
analysis
we start with the question what a
survival time analysis is
then we come to the important point what
the censoring of data means and finally
we discuss the kaplan-meier curve the
log-rank test and the cox regression
finally i'll show you how to calculate
all three methods online using data tab
this is an introductory video and there
are separate detailed videos for each of
the three topics listed below and with
that we start right away with the first
question
what is survival time analysis
survival time analysis is a group of
statistical methods in which the
variable understudy is the time until an
event occurs
what does time until the occurrence of
an event mean
in survival time analysis a variable is
used that has a start time and an end
time when a certain event occurs
the time between the start time and the
event
is considered in the survival time
analysis the period of time can be
measured for example in days weeks or
months
an example would be the time between a
drug rehabilitation
and the relapse of the respective person
the start time would be the end of the
rehabilitation
and the event under consideration would
be the relapse
for example you might be interested in
whether different types of treatments
have an impact
on the time until a relapse occurs
or as the name survival time analysis
suggests the classic example
the time until death after a disease
here the start time is the recognition
of the disease and the end time is death
in many cases it is of great interest
whether a certain drug for example has
an influence on the survival time or not
of course the event doesn't have to be a
negative one for example you could also
look at the time to return to work after
a burnout and the object under
investigation does not have to be a
human being in engineering for example a
common question is how long a component
lasts in a test bench here one could
then select various parameters and see
if they have an impact on survival time
so therefore
time doesn't need to have anything to do
with survival time but still we speak of
survival time and survival time analysis
how exactly does a survival time
analysis work
let's assume you are a dental technician
and you want to study the survival time
of a filling in a tooth
so your start time is the moment when a
person gets a feeling at the dentist
and the end time is the moment when this
feeling breaks out
so now you're interested in the time
between these two situations
now of course you need test persons
so that you have data that you can
evaluate
for each person you can now note the
time that passes until the feeling
breaks out
now the question will surely come up
what if the feeling of a test person
does not break out or what if the person
moves away and changes the dentist so it
is simply not known when the feeling
will break out
all these cases are summarized under the
term censoring what does that mean
first of all a study cannot last forever
there's always a start and an end date
because of limited resources and simply
because you want to publish the results
at some point
if a filling is inserted within this
period and then the filling breaks out
again within this period you have a
valid case the event has occurred
however it is also possible that a
filling is inserted and then the end of
the study is reached before the event
occurs
or it can happen that a test person
decides not to continue with the study
in both cases it is not known when or if
the event under consideration has
occurred or not what else can happen is
that another event occurs which is not
considered in a study for example the
patient under consideration could die or
lose the entire tooth due to whatever
circumstances
in both cases the event under
consideration that the filling breaks
out can no longer occur
another possible situation is that the
test person does not realize that the
feeling has broken out and this is only
discovered during the next routine
examination
so you can see that there are a lot of
cases where the data is not complete
this data is then called senzod data you
can find out how to handle this data in
my video on the kaplan-meier curve
now let's first look at the most popular
methods of survival time analysis
here we have the kaplan-meier survival
time curves the log rank test and the
cox regression
we will now briefly go into all three
areas
and i will then show you how you can
easily calculate these methods online
with data tab for each of the three
methods there's also a detailed separate
video and you can find the links in the
video description
let's start with the kaplan-meier curve
the kaplan-meier curve is used to
graphically represent the survival rate
or the survival function
the time is entered on the x-axis and
the survival rate on the y-axis
so what is the survival rate
let's look at the example of the dental
filling again here we have collected
data on how long it takes for a filling
to break out in the kaplan-meier curve
you can now see how likely it is that a
filling will last longer than a certain
point in time for example you might be
interested in how likely it is that your
feeling will last longer than let's say
five years
in order to do this simply go to five
years on the x-axis
and there you can see what the survival
rate is
at five years the kaplan-meier curves
gives you a value of
0.7
so it is 70 percent likely that a
filling will last longer than 5 years
of course the data are purely fictitious
if you are interested in how the
kaplan-meier curve is created from
existing data
please watch my video about that but now
you might be interested in whether this
curve differs according to different
filling materials for example whether
one filling material is better than the
other one
how do you find that out
the log rank test helps you with this
task the log rank test compares the
distribution of the time until an event
occurs
of two or more independent samples
for example you might be interested in
whether there is a difference in
survival time between two different
materials so in half of the participants
you use material a and in the other half
you use material b for the filling
the look rank test now gives you an
answer to the question
is there a significant difference
between the two curves or in other words
does the filling material have an
influence on the survival time of the
dental filling
with this knowledge we can now look at
the hypotheses in the log rank test
in a log rank test the null hypothesis
is there is no difference in terms of
the distribution of time until the event
occurs
and the alternative hypothesis is the
groups have different distribution
curves
so as always with a statistical
hypothesis test you get a p-value at the
end of the log-rank test
the question is whether this p-value is
greater than the significance level or
not
the significance level is set to
0.05 in most cases
if the calculated p-value is greater
than
0.05 the null hypothesis is retained
so based on the available data it is
assumed that both groups have the same
distribution curve if the p-value is
smaller than 0.05 the null hypothesis is
rejected
now you might ask yourself another
question
how can i test if there are other
parameters that influence the curve
not only do you want to know if the
material has an effect on survival time
but also you want to know if the age of
the people has an effect
for this you can use a cox regression
as i just said at the beginning for each
of these methods there is also a
detailed separate video now i will show
you how you can easily calculate all
three methods online with data tab
just go to datadeb.net you will find the
link in the video description
then you copy your own data into this
table and click on plus and then on
survival analysis
here we have a column with the time and
then a column that tells us whether the
event has occurred or not
if not the case is censored
here 1 stands for occurred and 0 4
censored
then we have the variable material with
the two materials a and b
and we have the age of our test people
depending on what you choose here the
appropriate methods are calculated for
you
if you select only the variable time the
kaplan-meier survival curve will be
calculated and you will get the
corresponding survival timetable
if no variable is specified with the
status it is assumed that no case is
censored if this is not the case you can
simply click here at status on the
variable that contains the data
whether the event has occurred or not
if you now select a factor for example
the material the log rank test will be
calculated
here you can read the null and the
alternative hypothesis
the null hypothesis is there is no
difference between groups a and b
in terms of the distribution of time
until the event occurs
and now you get the results here below
for example get the p-value
if you do not know exactly how to
interpret the results then you can
simply click on summary in words
the summary in words says a log rank
test was calculated to see if there was
a difference between groups a and b in
terms of the distribution of time to the
event occurrence for the present data
the log rank test showed that there is a
difference between the groups in terms
of the distribution of time until the
event occurs
p-value smaller than 0.01
the null hypothesis is thus rejected
if you click on the material and the age
the cox regression is calculated and
here below you can see if the factors
have a significant influence or not
more about this in my video on cox
regression
now we continue with the detailed video
on the kaplan-meier curve
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time